>>> GREAT JOB.
HIS TWEETS ANGERED THE MOB, NOW
HE'S OUT OF A JOB.
I SPEAK OF A 24-YEAR-OLD FROM
MICHIGAN.
AREN'T THEY ALL?
JAMES GRIFFIN GREEN MOVED TO THE
BRONX FOR A JOB IN NYC.
ALREADY WE KNOW HE HAS BAD
JUDGMENT.
UPON ARRIVAL HE HAD A HARD TIME
SHOPPING AT LOCAL BODEGAS WHICH
IS WHAT PEOPLE CALL ALL THE
SMALL GROCERY STORES IN NEW
YORK.
THESE ARE PLACES WHERE YOU CAN
BUY AND OVERPAY FOR DETERGENT,
BEER AND COLD MEDICINE WHILE A
CAT SLEEPS ON A LOAF OF WONDER
BREAD.
TAKE IT AWAY, GRIFFIN.
>> I JUST MOVED TO NEW YORK AND
I'M TRYING TO GO GROCERY
SHOPPING.
I'VE TYPED IN GROCERY STORES ON
APPLE MAPS.
EVERY ONE I GO TO I AM WALKING
TO.
THEY ARE LIKE THIS.
THIS IS NOT A GROCERY STORE.
I'M TRYING TO GET EGGS AND
YOGURT AND CHEESE.
LOOK AT THIS PLACE.
I'VE BEEN TO FIVE OF THOSE NOW.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M GOING TO
DO FOR DINNER.
WHERE IS KROGER.
WHOLE FOODS?
I AM BUYING CEREAL AND RAMEN FOR
DINNER.
>> GREAT.
THAT CLIP MADE THE ROUNDS ON
TWITTER WITH PEOPLE CALLING HIM
A RACIST.
SOME BUSYBODY LOSERS TWEETED HIS
NEW PLACE OF WORK A SOFTWARE
COMPANY CALLED OUTREACH
DEMANDING THAT HE BE FIRED, SO
THEY DID.
BUT NOW THEY SAY HE WAS FIRED
FOR SHARING A CONFIDENTIAL
EMPLOYMENT LETTER ON SOCIAL
MEDIA.
IT'S OBVIOUS THE MOB DID HIM IN
BY SCARING HIS EMPLOYER.
WE REACHED OUT TO GRIFF.
THAT'S WHAT I CALL HIM BECAUSE
WE ARE TIGHT.
WE THROW DOWN.
>> YOU JUST LIKE SAYING GRIFF.
>> WE THROW DOWN.
HE SAYS HE NEVER MEANT TO TRASH
THE NEIGHBORHOOD, ADDING, QUOTE,
THROUGH THIS EXPERIENCE I HAVE
LEARNED THAT FOOD DESERTS ARE A
HUGE ISSUE IN SOME URBAN AREAS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
NEW YORK SPECIFICALLY.
I HAD NO IDEA THIS IS WHAT I WAS
WALKING INTO.
I WAS ESSENTIALLY A GOLDEN
RETRIEVER THAT STUCK HIS NOSE IN
A BEES NEST AND GOT STUNG.
THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL ANALOGY.
HE ALSO FILMED HIMSELF BUYING
FOOD FROM BODEGAS AND
DISTRIBUTING IT TO THE HOMELESS,
WHICH IS FINE, I GUESS.
WHEN I DO MY CHARITY WORK I
NEVER RECORDED.
THAT IS TACKY.
ALSO THEY WON'T LET ME BRING MY
CAMERA INTO THE CHIP AND IN
DALE'S DRESSING ROOM.
JEFF, HERO OH?
>> I HAVE TO PICK HIM ONE OF
TWO?
>> YOU CAN SAY WAS HE RIGHT TO
BE FIRED?
IT WAS HIS SECOND DAY ON THE
JOB.
>> I AM SHOCKED THAT HE FOUND HE
WORKED IN TECH.
I THINK WE LEARNED A LESSON.
HE'S A BRO.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE ARE MAD.
I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES.
I'M A BRO.
I'M A STRAIGHT WHITE GUY.
HE'S GOT TO KNOW THAT YOU'VE GOT
TO LIVE.
YOU HAVE TO LIE EVERY DAY IF YOU
WANT TO KEEP WORKING.
YOU IDENTIFY AS A WOLF.
MY MOON IS RISING.
ME TOO.
MEN CAN HAVE BABIES.
>> YOU LIVE SO YOU CAN WORK.
THERE YOU GO.
HE WAS A VICTIM OF HIS OWN
NAÏVETÉ.
DID YOU SEE ANY TRUTH IN THERE?
>> EVERYTHING HE SAID WAS
ACCURATE.
HE JUST MADE THESE FILMS CLOSE
TO HIS FACE FOR MY TASTE.
I JUST AM SHOCKED.
YOU KNOW HOW YOU KNEW HE WAS
FROM OUT OF TOWN?
HE PAID FOR EVERYTHING.
>> DO YOU ALL STEAL?
>> YOU HAVEN'T BEEN IN NEW YORK
IN A WHILE.
>> IF HE WOULD HAVE ROBBED EVERY
PLACE HE WOULD HAVE WENT TO, HE
WOULD HAVE BEEN A HERO.
HE DIDN'T SINGLE ANYBODY OUT AND
HE GAVE FOOD TO THE HOMELESS.
CANCEL THIS GUY.
I HOPE THIS INSPIRES HIM.
USUALLY STORIES LIKE THIS WILL
TURN INTO THIS GUY OPENING
GROCERY STORES ALL OVER THE EAST
COAST.
HE WILL LOOK BACK ON THIS DAY
AND LAUGH.
>> I HAVE A THEORY THAT BODEGAS
ARE DESIGNED FOR PEOPLE LIKE
YOU.
SOMEBODY AT 2:30 A.M. IN THE
MORNING THAT IS INSIDE THESE
NARROW THINGS THINKING THEY WILL
BUY SOME HOSE.
I WILL BUY SOME JERKY.
I WILL BUY SOME CAT FOOD.
AND THEN YOU JUST BRING IT UP
THERE LIKE THIS.
>> YOU KNOW ME SO WELL.
>> IT IS DESIGNED FOR PEOPLE
BUYING STUFF WHILE THEY ARE
SLIGHTLY INEBRIATED AND NOT
LOOKING AT THE PRICES.
OR EVEN NOTICING THAT MAYBE IT'S
STALE UNTIL YOU OPEN IT UP.
>> IT USUALLY IS.
I FEEL LIKE I DO HAVE TO SAY
THIS GUY SUCKS.
NOT BECAUSE-HE SHOULD HAVE
GOTTEN FIRED.
BUT LOOK AT HIM.
THERE'S SO MANY SHIRTLESS GYM
MIRROR SELFIES OF HIM THAT ARE
FLOATING AROUND.
HE IS LIKE THE KIND OF GUY THAT
IS HITTING ON YOU AT A BAR AND
NEVER UNDERSTANDING NO MATTER
HOW OBVIOUS YOU ARE BEING ABOUT
NOT BEING INTO IT.
HE GETS EXCITED WHEN THE CHAIN
SMOKERS COME ON.
>> YOU ARE DESCRIBING YOUR
HUSBAND.
>> I RESEMBLED THESE COMMENTS.
>> I LOVE MY HUSBAND SO MUCH BUT
HE DOES HAVE THE MUSICAL TASTE
OF FOREVER 21.
IT DOES CREATE ISSUE SOMETIMES.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THAT LATER.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, EMILY?
I WAS PROBABLY CLOSER TO WHAT HE
WAS BACK THEN.
IF I HAD SOCIAL MEDIA AT THAT
AGE, I NEVER WOULD HAVE
SURVIVED.
I WOULD NOT HAVE A JOB.
>> BUT THE POINT IS WE DIDN'T.
THANK GOD WE DON'T HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
WE WERE PERFECT.
>> EXACTLY.
I DID NOTHING BAD.
>> I FEEL LIKE THE COMPANY
BREATHES A SIGH OF RELIEF WHEN
THEY SAW HE HAD POSTED THAT
OFFER LETTER.
NOW WE ACTUALLY DO HAVE THIS
LEGAL HOOK.
THEN THEY THREW IN THE COMMENT
ABOUT HOW THEY ARE DEDICATED TO
INCLUSION AND DIVERSITY JUST IN
CASE THE MOB COMES AFTER THEM
TOO.
THERE WAS A GOFUNDME ACCOUNT SET
UP FOR HIM.
HE HAS ALREADY RAISED OVER $4000
FOR HIMSELF.
>> THAT'S A LOT OF AX BODY
SPRAY.
>> THAT'S A LOT OF RAMEN.
HE WAS SAYING HE WAS SCREWED
BECAUSE NOW HE DOESN'T HAVE A
JOB AND HE IS STUCK HERE FOR 12
MONTHS WHICH IS LIKE A BILLION
DOLLARS.
>> WE COULD HIRE HIM HERE.
>> NO DZINGEL.
>> WE ALREADY HAVE HIS TWIN, THE
GUY IN THE BACK.
ANDRE.
HE IS ALWAYS THE GUY ASKING THE
MONKEY TO HAVE SEX.
THE ONLY TIME YOU HEAR HIS
VOICE.
>> HE COULD BE ANDRE.
THEY WOULD COMPETE FOR YOUR
AFFECTION.
>> THIS IS THE LAST BASTION OF
PERSECUTION.
CAN WE ADMIT THAT IT'S NOT
RACIST AT LEAST?
HE MIGHT BE DUMB, YOUNG AND
STUPID AND ON THE INTERNET AND
DEFINITELY ZOOMED I